All right, my friends, I am so glad you were
with me today, because we are going to need
a full week to unravel and talk through this
election the next weeks, months, years.
But the big news, of course, coming over the
weekend, multiple networks finally calling
the presidential election for Joe Biden.
Joe Biden has defeated Donald Trump and will
be the forty sixth president of the United
States, defeating Donald Trump by roughly
four point five million votes in the popular
vote.
We're still waiting on final numbers from
some states, but as of now, two hundred and
ninety to 214 in the Electoral College.
Georgia expected to push that to three hundred
and six electoral votes, the same number that
Donald Trump had in 2016, which at the time
he and Kellyanne Conway and others described
as a massive landslide victory.
And the world, with some few exceptions, has
breathed a collective sigh of relief.
It took days for networks to get comfortable
enough with the margin in Pennsylvania and
Nevada to call the election.
But they did on Saturday morning, leading
to the spontaneous breakout of happy people
singing and dancing in the streets quite literally
all over the world.
The communism didn't break out.
The suburbs weren't destroyed.
Toilets still flushed just once and worked
well enough.
But despite all of the things Trump said would
happen, that didn't happen.
Mostly masks at the events that broke out,
although some real concerns about coronavirus.
And we're going we're going to get to that.
Joe Biden will become the 43rd president.
Senator Kamala Harris, now Vice President
elect Kamala Harris, will become the first
woman in the White House as president or vice
president in the history of the United States.
Her husband will become the first ever second
gentleman of the United States, the first
Jewish person, man or woman as spouse of a
president or VP.
Now, despite this, Donald Trump has not yet
conceded the election.
Remember, concession is an irrelevant formality.
It is legally irrelevant, but concession is
what you would expect an adult to do.
Donald Trump continues to tweet, insists that
this was a stolen election, that there was
fraud or, as he says, fraud like a petulant
child.
And there is no telling how much longer he
will keep going.
He's even being reportedly pressured by Rudy
Giuliani and others to heart to start holding
rallies again.
Rallies not about people voting for him, but
rallies to build pressure for I guess recounts
will have more about that maybe tomorrow.
But just remember.
Come January 20th, twenty twenty one, Donald
Trump will no longer be president, but for
now he won't stop truly making a fool out
of himself, tweeting such gems as, quote,
Since when does the lame stream media call
who our next president will be?
We have all learned a lot in the last two
weeks.
Will remember when they called it for him
with far fewer electoral votes, not even 270
actually back in 2016.
He gladly accepted it.
Trump also tweeting in all caps.
The observers were not allowed into the counting
rooms.
I won the election got seventy one million
legal votes.
Bad things happened, which our observers were
not allowed to see, never happened before.
Millions of mail in ballots were sent to people
who never asked for them.
Now, that's not true.
There were Republican and Democratic observers
everywhere.
This concept of illegal votes is a disgusting
concept.
Something is either a vote from a person or
it is not.
Trump also tweeting, I won this election by
a lot.
Why have Trump and Republicans accepted the
results from the House and Senate, but not
the presidential results?
Everything was on the same ballots, my friends,
and almost poetic was the news that at the
time networks called the election Saturday
morning, Donald Trump was golfing.
Now, as far as Trump's next two months, he
might as well stay on the golf course for
all I care, to be perfectly frank, multiple
reports are that Trump's inner circle has
been trying to figure out who's going to go
in and tell him to concede.
Reportedly, his son in law, Jared Kushner,
trying to get him to concede maybe, although
contrasting reports that Kushner is saying
start doing rallies.
His wife reportedly, at least for now, his
wife.
We will see what happens with that after the
presidency is over.
Melania Trump reportedly also saying you should
concede, save some face, but others, like
Rudy telling him, do rallies.
So the focus now shifts to the Senate.
There will be two runoff elections in Georgia.
Those will ultimately decide who controls
the Senate for Joe Biden's first two years.
I will talk about that a little later.
Now, let's understand how good this is, but
also the limits problems aren't solved because
Trump is leaving.
We will all be staying vigilant.
We will all be keeping the Biden Harris administration
accountable.
And we have to deal with the virus.
We may not have the Senate, but this is a
major accomplishment.
It's OK to hold two conflicting feelings.
This is news worthy of rejoicing about removing
an incumbent president is difficult when we
talk about the power of incumbency.
It's not a talking point.
It's a real thing.
And yet at the same time, we still have so
many problems that now the work begins and
it will be big work.
There will also be plenty of time to talk
about the problems of the Democratic Party
because to be perfectly clear, massive recession,
record GDP decline, explosive unemployment
rate out of control, rent foreclosure crisis,
abject failure and dealing with a pandemic.
And Democrats barely got the presidency.
It came down to under one hundred thousand
votes in three states.
You could say it came down to under 50000
votes in two states.
It's unclear who will control the Senate.
So the Democratic Party eke this out just
barely and almost blew it.
And we have to talk about that as well.
It's not just the Democratic Party.
Trump ism has not been defeated.
Trump got more than 70 million votes and we
will talk about that.
So this should feel like what it is a great
start and this is how progress is made.
We are all correct to feel a combination of
panic and despair at 70 million people saying
give me another four years of Trump, but this
is when the work starts and we'll be going
through
all of it.